[Music]
hey Vsauce how are you doing it's
Michael here at the 2010 New York Comic
Con and I'm joined by Ramana myself and
rusty are going to be counting down the
top superheroes to have a child with so
I'm going to let you be my first victim
what superhero would you want to have a
child get and why Captain America okay
good he's a shield you can protect you
but you know he knows he knows how to
get a little violent oh wow I didn't
know that if you could have a have a
child with any superhero who would it be
Wonder Woman Lady Deadpool someone that
doesn't slide why I don't want to like
you know
what am I gonna do definitely not to fly
off the fly you don't lash naughty
invisible man nothing is gonna make it
difficult
maybe the fly the glob all right if you
could have a child with any superhero
what superhero would it be oh that's
pretty sad
Superman you see be a super baby but
it's a very easy question because all
the superheroes certainly have anger
management issue
ilysm or something it's Superman a dozen
and who's going to be going to
kryptonite anytime soon so I think
there's a shopper good offspring in
vitro in vitro surrogate baby surrogate
Deadpool you're wearing Green Lantern
and still dead I'm mark fast
all right go Marvin are you still marvel
fan now will the baby be disfigured like
weight
probably but that'll be good because I
can dress them up in like a little
satchel outfit maybe so few probably
guys probably gambit I'm sorry
rogue alright alright no you probably
die yeah but it'd be worth it man White
Queen white winged Wolverine over eight
the Baroness the Baroness this Baron wow
wow that is for did you know that I
didn't wow this is a revelation right
now where the right now they just
expressed their love for each other or
he expressed his love for hurt it's gone
unreciprocated which is awkward for the
rest of the day so there you go those
are the answers we got at Comic Con but
let me know who you would choose in the
comments below remember it would be a
kid that was half you and half whichever
superhero you pick okay so put it in the
comments and imma throw it over to Jeff
to curate all of the other stuff that
Vsauce barely political rusty Andre
fetch Co blah blah blah blah blah did at
comic-con it's a lot of it help us out
boom wacky gamer that's me and Adam we
shout a bunch of videos gameplay right
here and our continuing series of nerd
wars where we put too nerdy characters
against each other
we ask the cosplayer right here under
your fetch go from barely political and
her own channel under your fetch Co did
a nice little video on our hot mess
series when she was dressed as a
cosplayer Princess Leia in her slave
outfit what's up that great video here
rusty Ward from barely political he did
a great video where he went and asked
are you smarter than a booth babe
interviewing both booth blades and
attendees
here and dr. coolsex did a great Mario
cosplay video where they went and
invaded a comic-con as Mario and did a
whole bunch of integers of people you
check that out right here
seriously click my chest
Oh
you